so this is lecture 15. and today we'll
be talking about code generation so
a little bit unusual since it's a we'll
be generating unnatural languages this
time
but it'll connect in a number of ways to
natural language Generation
Um so before I start just a few
announcements
the project Milestone is due this
Thursday you are certainly aware of that
um
and also when doing the projects it's
always good to keep track of how much
you're spending on Azure in AWS
and one thing to notice is that disk
costs money like it doesn't cost that
much
compared to gpus but it still costs
something for me be sure to not
be spending all your money on on disk
um
so tomorrow John will be running a
discussion on training large language
models
it'll be really cool um so it'll be at 3
30.
in the skinny Auditorium there's more
details on that
and this Thursday we have our first
invited talk
in our regular lecture time and
attendance is expected so
please everyone show up it'll be really
cool
um
all right so let's let's get started
so
we'll be talking about a problem
that in the literature is called Perkin
synthesis and let's see what that means
so Perkin synthesis is actually a pretty
old uh challenge of artificial
intelligence and the goal is to write
programs to create programs that can
take some sort of specification and
write a program that satisfies that
specification so it's a program that
writes a program
uh so so that's what a program
synthesizer is right it's a program
that's
takes your specification and is able to
generate some program
and then you can ask what kind of
specification
um so one possible specification for
example could be a logical formula it
could be uh like a mathematical formula
that specifies what Behavior we want
from the program
it could be an equivalence program
so I could say okay here is a slow
implementation of the Sorting algorithm
bubble sorts for example and it runs in
O of N squared and I want to synthesize
another program that's equivalent so it
generates all the the same outputs given
the same inputs but it's maybe faster so
that could be a form of specification
um
I could give examples right I could say
Okay I want a program that if I give you
if I give it this input it should
generate this output if I give this
string it should should give me back
this ring
um or as more popular these days we
could also
maybe in addition to or instead of these
other kinds of specifications also give
a natural language description right I
could just write I want a program that
performs certain a certain operations
and
so so just to warm up let's see how this
synthesis from logical specifications
could look like
um so when would it make sense to use
the program synthesizer at all
um
so it would only make sense to use a
program to write a program for us if
that's in some way easier than writing
the program ourselves right
so there should be
it should be easier to specify what the
program does compared to exactly how it
should do that
so let's
and this is um different than natural
language generation an important way in
that we usually have ways to test our
output automatically right so if if I
give the synthesizer okay I want a
program that given these inputs
generates these outputs and this
synthesizer gives me back a program I
can go in there and execute the program
on the inputs that I gave and verify
that it generates the correct outputs
and and this is different than a natural
language task for example if I ask it to
summarize
an article or in a paragraph and it
gives me back a response and I can
evaluate it in some ways I can compare
it to a true human reference summaries
or
or I can use a language model to
to evaluate the output of another
language model but but in I can't like
execute the summary and verify that it's
a good summary
um
so
yes
certain that the output is always
correct considering like
I mean without formal verification how
can you just make sure that the output
program is correct since you'll be
posting to the iOS on the test cases
only yeah that's a good question so the
question was how can I make sure that
the output is correct uh in general well
it depends on what specification we have
right if this specification is input
output examples all we can do is verify
that it satisfies those examples we'll
talk about the problem with that in a
little bit
um
any other questions about this I'll give
an example so it would be very concrete
starting
um okay so let's see how this could work
let's try to specify a program using the
sort of logical specification
um
so our first attempt will be to specify
how do I sort an array right I want a
program that receives an array as input
and returns a sorted array so how would
I write that mathematically
our first attempt could be well let's
say that this program takes an array a
and outputs on array B
um I can specify that I want the array B
to be sorted right so mathematically I
could write that as for all of the
indices I of the output I want the
element at that index should be smaller
than the OR at most the the next element
right so like sorted in increasing order
second
look at the statement and say okay so if
if the output satisfies that then it's a
sorted array
um
does this look good
maybe right so I can give that
specification to a synthesizer and then
it'll go and search for programs that
satisfies this and then it returns this
program
which is called sword takes an array a
and Returns the array 1 2.
so if you look at the mathematical form
let's say well for all of the indices of
the output that element is smaller than
or equal to the next element so it
satisfies the specification that we gave
but of course not the program we wanted
um
and then
okay so maybe we missed something we
missed that
the output not only should be sorted but
also should have the same elements as
the input right so I can specify that as
like uh I want the array B to have the
same length as array a and has to be a
permutation for each element of the the
output has to be somewhere there in the
input
um
and then
writing a little bit more formally in
first of the logic it would look like
that don't have to try to parse it and
then if I give that to the synthesizer
maybe to go and search for some programs
and return like quick sort or some
function that actually sorts Theory
um so
notice that the problem here is it's
quite non-trivial because the formula as
little as it is it doesn't tell us how
to sort the rate just says that the rate
should be sorted in some way so it's not
just a syntactical translation between
the synthetic the the the the formula
that we gave and the the programming
language that that we're targeting
um
but the thing that's obvious here is
that these logical specifications are
quite hard to read they're quite hard to
write of course and also to check right
if I just gave you the the formula that
says and resorted
maybe at first it's not easy to see the
corner case that just being sorted is
not enough
um
and
I mean if I tell you that we are
making a synthesizer that takes this
formula and returns like a function that
sorts an array you could reasonably say
that maybe it's just easier to write the
function yourself
but it is quite a challenge to this or
even then
any questions about the
the setup here
okay
so maybe it's maybe logical forms are
too much right we don't want to be
specifying even simple programs like
sorting with those ugly first order
formulas we could try something simpler
we could try examples
right so input output example is a very
natural kind of specification and in
fact when writing program software
Engineers usually already write tests
which are kind of like input output
examples right like if I call the
function with this input should return
this I assert that it does that
um so how could I specify sorting in
that case
I could say well if I give the array 3 2
1 0 it should return 0 1 2 3
for 142 which would return one to four
and four nine should return 9. any
human looking at these inputs and
outputs could reasonably guess that oh
maybe it's just like sorting the input
array right
um
but as we just saw with this the The
Logical synthesizer
we could
also get a program that looks like this
well if the array has exactly four
elements return zero one two three and
if it's if it has three returns this
exact array and otherwise always return
nine right satisfies the input output
examples but somehow it's still not what
we want
um
of course this is a
kind of an adversarial output
um
and synthesis by example was actually
massively used in the last decade
because of this feature in Excel called
Flash Fill
which was
released in in 2013 and it was for a
while one of the hottest things to have
happened to Microsoft Excel
um so uh flash flow is this really cool
feature where uh the goal is to for
Excel to guess what string
transformation you're applying so you
can write for example uh if you have a
column that has
people's first and last names and you
want to just get the the first name for
example of everyone and you create the
second column and you type like in this
example Ned
um then Excel if you like click on the
flash flow button it will magically
guess that what you're doing is you're
splitting on the space and maybe taking
the first of those strings and suggest
to complete that as the second column
and it can actually do quite complex
Transformations and usually from one or
two examples and it's quite cool
um
but as is clear at this point
synthesis from examples
has there's a hearing problem of
ambiguity right for any
set of examples input output examples
that I give there will be usually an
infinite number of programs that that
have that exactly that behavior on those
examples right
um
but somehow
that's very non-human because humans
for some reason have a very specific
preference over this over this Infinite
Space of programs
um like if I look at at this program
that does this even if I don't tell you
what kind of program was I looking at in
the first place it's it's very obvious
that like the previous problem not
useful for anything right
um but it's obvious for you not through
a synthesizer necessarily that's trying
to do
to find a program
um so for example what program am I
specifying here with these two examples
Jan uh transform to January and fabric
transforms through February
any human guess is about what this
should do
name from nothing expensive yeah exactly
it should obviously do that but for a
while I think maybe not EX
I'm not sure if this fix was released or
is going to be released but for a while
this is what flash would do
um
it would complete Feb with February
March with Maria Maria
and so on right so it guessed from one
example oh what you're doing is just
concatenating your area on the string
that you had right so
clear the extrapolation
any other possible strings that you
might want so
how
do we do we deal with this right with
this ambiguity we'll talk a little bit
about that but just to summarize what we
we've seen so far a synthesizer is this
program that takes some form of
specification of what a program should
do and then generates a program
and if we get this to work this would
actually have massive impact in a number
of ways right it can lower the barrier
to to access programming through a lot
of
of people that maybe don't want you
should be spent four years taking CS
classes so for example people can
automate a lot of things just by using
flashfree on XL things that would take a
lot more time
and even programmers ourselves can
benefit from much higher productivity we
can program it higher level ways so this
is quite an interesting goal but it of
course has many challenges right it has
this Infinite Space of programs a lot of
them are unreasonable unreasonable in
this human way
and here we're talking about at least
for now right searching in the in a
space of programs in a very specific
language where you can do search but
it's of course impractical you do search
in any real world languages like python
uh and we we have this ambiguity problem
right like how do you capture human
preferences
um so we'll talk here about the
connection between this problem of
ambiguity in program synthesis and
natural language which is extremely
common
so human languages are extremely
ambiguous and if you stop to look at it
more closely it's actually quite
surprising that we managed to
communicate so well and so easily
um even though if you look up almost any
word in the dictionary it'll have like a
large number of meanings that it might
have even sentences out of context
generally have multiple interpretations
but we somehow do just fine talking in
English in this very ambiguous
um medium and in fact ambiguity is not
even a bug of human languages it's a
feature and it's a feature for
efficiency so actually there's this this
paper here that's really cool that
provides true arguments based on
information theory that any
communication Channel where
basically the meaning of
words can be disintegrated in context
we'll make those words at some point
Collide to make them both short so for
example if I have uh Bear the animal and
bear the verb they usually appear in
very different contexts right so it
would actually be very inefficient to
create your word to separate those uh
with because at some point I would be
adding both more and longer words to my
vocabulary right so if they can be
disembly graded a
true to be often when a formal
communication perspective I'll actually
get an ambiguity at some point
um and there's one very interesting
uh challenge for computers to to resolve
this kind of ambiguity called the
winogram renograd schema challenge
and if you read the examples they're
quite entertaining because you read them
it's very obvious what's going on but
it's also obvious what's the challenge
so so here we have these two sentences
the city councilman refused the
demonstrators a permit because they
feared violence and the obvious
ambiguity here is that they could refer
to the city councilman or the
demonstrators right but when you're here
they feared violence
what's the obvious candidate here for
what they refer to
yeah exactly
um and when you say the advocated
violence then you suddenly process the
sentence in a different way right and
syntax the senses are exactly the same
right but just because of your your
prior knowledge about how these actors
behave in the world yeah you use that to
disintegrate the two different means
um yeah so this is very easy for us
right handling this kind of ambiguity
and how do you do it it's it's an
interesting question how do humans do
this
and the the linguistic uh
term for the kind of reasoning that we
do in this in this setting it's called
pragmatic reasoning right so in
linguistics we have this distinction
between semantics and pragmatics of how
do we attribute meaning to things right
like semantics talks about
like the intrinsic meaning of words in a
certain sense in pragmatics how does
that change in context
um
and to do this kind of resolution of
ambiguity we
we have to operate with some sort of
assumption that helps us get off the
ground and one important assumption here
is this Assumption of cooperativity so
when we're talking to someone we assume
that they're trying to help us
understand what they're saying right so
they want the adverse area as the
program synthesizer uh was in those
examples
and wheels we can use that assumption to
do reasoning context and perform
pragmatic reason
so I'll show here one model
uh of
pragmatic reasoning called the RSA or
rational speech acts which is a based on
what of how this could work in simple
scenarios so here we have uh we assume
that we have two people like a speaker
and a listener right the speaker
wants to refer to a certain
object or a person and it's going to
choose an utterance for that like a word
or a sentence to refer to that object
right and then the listener on the other
side is receiving those utterance and
trying to infer okay what does the
speaker
mean what what do they what are they
referring to what objects or what person
so one really quick example here on the
right is this where you have
these two people and then the person on
the right has my friend has glasses and
there are three people here there is one
person wearing no glasses and no hat
there's a person just wearing glasses
and a person wearing a glass and a hat
when you
hear that this person saying my friend
has glasses well it's of course
ambiguous in this case because there are
two people wearing glasses but
does anyone have an intuition of who
would you guess they're talking about
yes
like the most distinguished or the only
distinguishing Factor of the past yeah
the middle one is the one you go to
because if you wanted
exactly
describe the receipt basically so we do
this kind of recursive reasoning
apparently right where we think okay so
if they wanted to refer to the person
with the hat they could have said hat
and that would have not been a big use
but they did not say hat
which probably means something about
what they what they intended to to refer
to right
um so RSA is a very simple Bayesian
model
of exactly this this process so just to
work through an example let's say that
we have these three objects of a blue
square a circle which is also blue and
then a green square and we have these
four utterances that we can use a very
small vocabulary like blue green circle
and square
so in RSA we will bootstrap this process
from a literal listener which is a
listener that can only understand letter
meaning so
um
the if you give this listener some
whether it's you
The Listener will the literal listener
which we'll call it l0 will put uniform
probability on all the objects that
satisfy you so if you say blue will put
Okay so
uniform over all the blue objects if you
say squares will put uniform probability
over the squares and that's
the distribution of beliefs that the
literal listener puts
um so assuming that you're talking to
that lateral listener now you can create
a pragmatic speaker which will choose
some utterance to refer to an object
based on the probability that the
literal listener will understand what
they're saying
so basically for each of the words in
our or utterances that I could say maybe
it could be extremely specific like I
could write a text exactly describing
that object but that would be very
costly right so I want to be concise but
at the same time I can't be true concise
because otherwise I might not specify
what I want to say like I will not be
understood right so I can imagine this
pragmatic speaker S1 which is trying to
maximize this balance between the
probability that the the lesson the
literal listener will guess the the
intended object minus some cost which in
this case could be uniform probably
and then
from that pragmatic listener now I can
create a pragmatic speaker that will
choose an audience based on the
probability that the pragmatic speaker
would have chosen that order to refer to
that object
sorry the the the the the listener L1
would choose an object we'll guess a
belief over the object based on the
probability that the speaker S1 would
have chosen data to refer to each of the
objects
and here I could recourse right I could
create a listener L2 which reasons about
the the speaker
sorry I could choose a speaker as S2
which is
if talking with the listener L1 in in
their head and then a lesson or true and
so on
um but usually this listener speaker
bear S1 L1
is often enough to model human judgments
in these settings
this doesn't make sense what
how this recursive process is happening
okay
um
yeah so assuming these three objects and
a speaker says blue
um again following the same example of
the glasses and hats what we do
yes or what's your first intuition about
what object they would refer to
yeah the square is typically what people
what people do so a little listener
would say okay it's completely ambiguous
right like 50 on the Square and on the
circle but if you set up a human
experiment where people are receiving
these utterances and saying how much
they believe each of the objects is the
intended object they will put around 40
probability on the the circle in 60 on
the Square which is very close to what
RSA predicts
um
okay so this gives a mechanism for
resolving ambiguity in this listener
speaker setting
and
one way to see fragrance synthesis is
a setting where we are the speakers
right we're talking to the synthesizer
and we are speaking for example input
output examples
um
and I we want to refer to a certain
program like from a set of programs and
we're we're speaking uh examples and the
synthesizer is our listener which is
trying to ring for what program are we
referring to
and
we the the examples that we were seeing
the synthesize was being extremely
literal right
so like oh if you say
that given a it should return B could be
n of the programs that exist at return b
um
but
now we have a process that can maybe
refine this reasoning a little bit right
we have RSA and we can almost directly
apply it in the setting where we can
build a
this meaning Matrix where in one
dimension we have all the programs so
let's
assume for Simplicity that we have like
a finite set of programs and also a
finite set of of examples that can be
given to the synthesizer
so in that setting we can make this
Matrix where
each entry corresponds to a program
being ran on one example and we have one
if the program satisfies that example
like returns true or another example for
example and zero otherwise right
so this Matrix directly gives us a
literal listener for this setting like
if I say if I give an example and a
little synthesizer could just look at
this table and say okay these are all
the programs that set aside those
examples maybe I'll sample one of those
at random
um but I could use the RSA recursion to
derive L1 and now true right and those
would be uh
like pragmatic synthesizers and in a
human experience ran into this paper
which I won't get in a lot of the thing
in their setting but
they they ran this
um this experience where people were
trying to specify a program that draws a
pattern on a
like a grid and the the specification
was through examples by basically saying
okay like the pattern contains the
square or does not contain the square
and people had a much easier time
communicating
the pattern that they wanted with the
pragmatic synthesizer
um
which is a quite cool result I think
um yeah so of course the assumptions
here are that the set of programs and of
examples is finite which is quite
restrictive it is it's not true of real
programming languages but
it does present an interesting challenge
right like can we extend this this kind
of approach to during
the infinite set of programs like real
programming languages and also maybe
also we want richer kinds of
specifications really instead of just
saying
um the behavior the program in specific
examples we could try to handle natural
language
um any questions about
this connection between
yes
consider in this whole program synthesis
just generally how we would typically
want like a simple like with this sorted
example like how we had different like
edge cases
would do we have do we account for the
fact that would we penalize a like
longer program or more complicated
program when trying to consider
something like that yeah so so the
question was
in Perkins synthesis do we
do people use biases like find the
shortest program for example where like
the simplest perfume that satisfies the
specification and
the question is both yes and no
um
it's yes in the sense that
most search-based synthesizers both
usually find very short programs
but not because people
use that as a bias necessarily for for
this ambigrating but just because it's
much easier to find Trader programs so
like if you're doing
if you're doing search in a space of
programs like the chance that you find
like 100 line program that satisfies the
specification is naturally much smaller
than you finding a short one
um
now to be able to do search in the first
time a lot of research in this area in
the last decades has been true exactly
how to design
like specific languages and search
spaces so that this can be this can be
done
does that make sense
any other questions
okay um
so
we've been talking a lot about language
models in the class
and as you know
if I give a prefix of
anything that can show up in the
internet right language model gives me a
distribution of what can come next so
for example if I say Stanford University
is located in the state of
the model having been trained on
Wikipedia and other sources would put
much higher probability on the centers
continued with California rather than
another U.S state
um
language model is quite hard uh it's
like a really really hard problem
because as John talked about in his
lecture a lot of things can be reduced
to language modeling right so if I say
theater Landon streleski a former grad
student
in mathematics at Stanford for example
when I asked u53 to give plausible
completions it gives became known for
his advocacy of the use of psychedelic
drugs or homeless Advocate
um and I mean this sound
plasma maybe the ground truth in this
case from Wikipedia is he murdered his
former advisor
which might be quite hard to predict
given this prefix
um
and it turns out that a
if I give gpt3
a prefix such as the follow is a python
function that when given the list 132
returns one two three it'll complete
exactly with this program deaf short
list
lsd.sort return list
um which
depending on what year you were born is
quite surprising right like it's it's
quite amazing that a model that
can predict California from Stanford
University is located in
with the exact same mechanism can
generate valid python code
um so this was a realization that
people made very quickly after gpt3 came
out right like given simple Python block
strings it was able to generate
python functions that implemented those
dark strings even without having been
trained explicitly for that or even code
was not like a large part of Jupiter 3's
training set anyway
um so
the natural question was like how how
far I'm going to push that capability
right so code is massively available
available on the internet GitHub has
tens of millions of
open source repositories like actually
over 120 million uh
as as of I think end of last year so
what happens if you just train a
language model on a lot of code
right so that was basically the idea
behind open air codecs
which is the name of the language model
that backs GitHub co-pilot just out of
curiosity how many of you have used
Copilot
okay less than I then I would have
thought maybe 30 percent
um
yeah so
co-pilot is this
basically auto complete on steroids that
runs uh
this language model called codex on the
back end great and
as a lot of papers in in this age we
live in the technical the technical
description of what was done was we took
the architecture of gpt3 maybe change
the number of parameters and trained on
this data uh yes
models would you just be looking
um kind of for um similarity to Gold
Standard code or are you also checking
for like
yeah that's a great question we'll talk
a lot about
how these these models are evaluated in
in some settings
the
the answer just joking ahead a little
bit would be that we'll mostly execute
the code and see what it does rather
than just comparing to reference
Solutions
um
there is a literature on how to evaluate
when you can't do that but
um s happens with natural language
people realize that blue scores and
adaptations are not actually very good
for functional correctness espec
especially in code where you can change
one token and not change the blue score
by much but completely change the the
semantics of the program
yes
in the training data did we include
natural language like uh for like it
like if we have like a function in
Python just like natural language like
describing what the function does like
in a comment or something
uh yeah so the question was did they
includes natural language in the
training data and yes in true forms so
code already has a lot of natural
language like comments and strings and
this was all kept like none of them none
of it was stripped um
so that's one form of natural language
that that codex got and the other one
was just a subset of the training side
of vp3 so it was not training 100 just
code it also had like so fun in it when
you get over there examples of Life a
natural language description of a
function and then the corresponding
python
uh so the question was was there a
description like were there examples in
the training date of a description and
then the function yeah
um
yes
um so that there are some examples of
that form that naturally if you're on
GitHub uh they're not
a lot compared to all all code that
exists
we'll talk a little bit about
dude yes yes
yeah so the web has a lot of of that
kind of thing in general right
um
one of we'll be talking about one
experiment that they did on fine tune it
exactly that format and then has an
impact because most
code is not written like that on the
internet although some fraction
definitely is
um
the answer
um yes so
the version one of codex was essentially
the same architecture as gpd3 which is a
decoder only transformed model
but with 12 billion parameters and then
train on a training set that was
constructed mostly from GitHub but also
natural language sources
um
yeah so how to evaluate a model right
like we trained it and we can prompt it
with a few examples and see that it does
interesting things but how do we we get
a better sense of of its capability
um so the
the author is in the paper uh in the
Codex paper they set up this challenge
of given a python lock string just
generate a function that implements that
dot string and where the doc string all
always had input output examples in the
form of assertions so
in this example here on the right
which is one from the paper right
um
so the first one uh the the goal is to
return a list with all the elements
increased by one so you would infer that
the elements or numbers and then they
give two examples which are like Pi dog
tests you can actually run these tests
uh automatically right so if I call it
with one two three it should return two
three four and they give one more
example and besides those examples
because if you
as machine learning people uh you should
know if you just give all the examples
that are evaluating on you're subject to
the program just working on those
examples but not on held out examples so
for each of these problems they of
course also had held out inputs that the
mod was evaluated on
but since this father has seen a lot
more code than any person has any chance
of ever looking at in their lifespan how
do you even know that the problems that
you're giving have not been seen before
so this becomes an increasingly
difficult challenge with these large
models so they did a best attempt which
was to create a data set of their own
since the goal here
is not to train on that data set you
don't need that many examples
as as you would need to to train a model
from scratch so they came up with these
problems of this form
that they basically manually author it
so that's
a way of
of saying that okay the model at least
hasn't seen these problems in this exact
form right
um
and for each one they had a set of
hidden tests so here the evaluation will
be does the generated program run
correctly on all the tests the the scene
and unseen ones and
the main metric that we'll be looking at
is what they call Passat K which is the
probability that out of case samples of
programs that I take from the model at
least one of them passes all of the the
tests
and the main result here is that
gpt3 which is also a quite large model
trained and a lot of code uh relatively
speaking
thus exactly
uh at zero in this Baseline in this
Benchmark that they came up with so it
doesn't solve any of the problems which
is good they're at least not trivial
trivia problems right and all of the
Codex models have some non-trivial
performance so codex alone
looking at pass at one which is like
just sample one program from the model
that's above 20 percent
and of course we have to take all these
numbers relative like 20 in general
doesn't mean much but it solves some
problems that gpt3 alone doesn't solve
right and
and
um
if they generated a set
of problems with this exact format of
python.string another function
to evaluate if this format was kind of
unusual for the model right so they
are kind of synthetically generated uh
like a training center fine tune and
called the resulting model called Xs and
yes codex that's a little bit better
well so it seems like
there's something to be
uh there's there's a little bit of
benefit of
design training date exactly with this
format
and
besides just sampling one
program and
returning that as your answer one theme
that we'll see here is that it's usually
worth your sample a lot more programs
and somehow choose which one is your
best bet one simple way to do that is
just by taking the model's load
probability over the sample right so
this is the
the the red line here which improves on
both of the others and if you look at
the the examples that sir
oh yes so the purple line is the Oracle
re-ranking which is basically like if I
take all the programs that are generated
and actually run them on the on the the
hidden tests and take the ones that pass
the hidden tests then
so what the purple line is saying is
that it's often the case that codex
generates some program that satisfies
all the tests but it might be hard to
identify without actually running the
program which one is it
um
so we'll look if you look at the
examples of samples from the model it's
it's quite non-trivial right so if I
describe a function like
def is prime uh returns true if a number
is prime which is
of course a problem that the model has
seen before in some form
um
it will
fail a lot of times but most of the
times it will do something reasonable so
here we will try to you see that it's
trying to
test for divisors of the number in this
case it's just missing the corner case
that's true I think or no that one is
returning as a prime number
it often returns
the same program so by resampling you
don't have any guarantees
it's Illustrated on GitHub so it it's
also seen a lot of incomplete code so it
might say to do pass do it later
um but yeah sometimes it works sometimes
it'll do exactly
the the primary test with all the corner
cases and all
and
if you specify a more complicated
function with maybe some more coordinate
cases
error again in this case it will not
solve it completely with any of the the
samples
but a lot of the samples are
surprisingly reasonable right like it
will often at least partially do what uh
the specification is asking you yes
how difficult are those tests and
they're like the store that made by
humans to specify even some tasks are
more difficult than others
yeah so uh so the question is how hard
are the tasks in general and these
problems are not hard for
human programmers
um in general so
they test basically
like basic capabilities of coding in
Python
um
so
there's
this is maybe a problem of like median
difficulty in the the training set in
the data set right like a functional
like counts vowels but has a special
case for why why should only be about if
it's at the end for example so this is
the general flavor of these problems
in the Codex paper we'll talk about
different data sets that makes sense
um yeah so the finding here oh yes so
like
it fails in a lot of cases but
many times producing is reasonable
guesses of what the function should do
and
one
thing to notice is that
one thing that they noticed was which
was an important observation for
many of the works that came after is
that there seems to be quite a large
benefit in just sampling more programs
and trying more so the space of
fragrance that the model can
can generate usually contains some
correct programs
and when simply more
there is a trade-off between
the sampling temperature and How likely
it is that the program is correct right
so if I sample with a temperature zero
then I basically get deterministic
Behavior I don't get any benefit from
from Recently but if I sample with too
high of a temperature then I I get more
and more random outputs right
um
uh yeah so
but of course just uh sampling more
programs
is maybe fine for this kind of
evaluation with the Benchmark but
when interacting with a user I of course
don't want to give the user 100 options
to choose from for instance like there's
a hyper I believe that one of these many
programs satisfies what you want but I
don't know which one it would not be
very usable
um
so of course I could just sample a small
number of programs but knowing that it's
usually the case that
in a large number of samples
one of them will be correct
it a lot of times makes sense to sample
a large number of programs and then try
to re-rank them in some way and then
only show maybe my top guesses
so the Oracle here would be
I ran all the programs in a test but a
lot of times I don't have that like if
I'm in the middle of writing function
writing I want some
some guess for how to write a certain
line of the function and might not have
tests for for that specific line
um but I can for example use the models
on log probability distribink
and
yeah what they found was that
basically taking the average token block
probability
among a number of
slightly more fancy ways of trying to
rank
was was the best that they could get
um
and here we were trying to sample code
given box string but one of the Magics
of language models is that
I can just condition them anything to
try to get anything I'm not guaranteed
to get good things but I can always try
um
so what if you try to use the model to
give me a doc string given the code so
basically describe what a function does
so that's a very natural version of the
problem that that we had before
and
that kind of data is
certainly way less frequent in the in
the training set although it certainly
exists in some cases because naturally
in python.strings comes before the code
but
this is
also very common thing with code data I
can usually manufacture synthetic data
sets that change the structuring in some
ways right so I can
basically write a deterministic program
that takes python functions and inverts
the the code in the dark string and make
a training set for this task
and in this case I lose the ability to
automatically evaluate if a dog string
actually describes the code
um that's well like I get a problem with
natural language generation where Lisa
talked about evaluations quite hard in
the Codex paper they evaluated this by
hand so basically pass that k
of where fastest a human said that the
doctrine describes the function and
surprisingly this task seems to be
harder than generating code from Doc
strings
itself
so even a fine-tuned model like so here
codex
s
is the the Codex that we saw that was
fine to intro to solve the tasks and
codex D was fine-tuned on this data set
of generating blocksprings given code
and in this case they didn't get any
benefits from fine tuning or any
improvement from the base model that
they started with
um so it seems like maybe describing
code is not that easy compared to
writing
um
so
sorry I have a question
ensure that the programs that are
generated compiled like we take
advantage of like parts
yeah so direction is how do you know
that they compile in this case they just
literally save the code and ran with the
python
so if it through an exception it failed
basically if it ran and produced the
exact output then it succeeded
um
curious because to other people we just
think of it as like a reading
comprehension gymnastics and like
because I couldn't actually think of a
measurement there but like is there any
similarity between that has been the
evaluate that path and the specific uh
has to describe
yeah so the question was can we see it
as like a reading comprehension task of
sorts
um for code and and yes basically it's
it's a waiter probe how well can the
model
understand quote-unquote what the code
does
that is one task
that is like of code understanding you
know so to speak another one is code
execution like given this code in this
input
what output does it produce which I'll
talk a little bit about but it's it's
also quite a hard task for for these
models so they're often able to produce
code that works
but if you give it the code then the
input it's
hard to predict what the code does from
the one
that makes sense
um
yeah so how how is code a different core
position is it more difficult
um
yeah I think more or less difficult to
depends your home right like an average
human
certainly can't describe what a python
function does but not necessarily
because like it's inherently more
complex task
um so I guess it depends on who who you
ask
um
yeah
the examples of the model got wrong is
there a way to do an analysis of the
source of the error like if there was an
error with the algorithm versus just
like a syntax error yeah so the question
is what kind of Errors does the model do
make and
can we evaluate it automatically yes I
didn't include this here but one of the
papers
that I'll talk a little bit about did
this analysis of what
what kind of of error does the model
make at different scales and the result
there was that
as the models grow in in number of
parameters they tend to make less
syntactic
errors and less compilation areas and
have more semantic errors like program
still runs but fails on some tests
um and at the
the smaller size is it's way more common
to get like syntax errors like didn't
close the parenthesis
um okay
so
as you've noticed the base technology
here was still just transformed right
we're sampling
from a Transformer and running the code
and maybe sampling more and re-ranking
using log probabilities but not nothing
extremely specific true
to code besides the fact that we can
execute the output deepmind
came up with Alpha code which was
very talked about I'm sure at least some
of you have heard of it which was
basically a system that expanded on
these ideas of training language models
to generate code
and in this case their target was to
solve programming competition problems
which
some of you might heard about these are
compositions just like math competitions
but where
the challenges to come up with
algorithms then then write code that
that solve a computational problem
um
and
the base
the foundation of alpha code was still
sampling from Transformers a lot of
their technical design choices was were
basically targeted allowing faster
sampling right so
they came up with
a cheaper version of attention where
you you share the
the key value has but have multiple
query heads because that was a an
engineering bottleneck in their sampling
and
the user encoded decoder Transformer
because was faster to just encode the
problem once
but aside from that very similar ideas
so they pre-trained
their Transformer on
basically in this case mostly code
I think from their description it was
basically just a data set composed of
GitHub code where the encoder was
additionally trained with mass language
modeling laws
and they fine-tuned
the model then on a much smaller data
set of Human Solutions to programming
competition problems which are much
sparser than like arbitrary GitHub code
um they used one variant of
reinforcement learning fine tuning
called gold not oral HF but
kind of similar idea just
in the the spirit that you don't want to
penalize the model for not being able to
produce all valid Solutions you just
wanted to be able to Output some
solution so if it's if assembly from the
model is giving you some solution then
it should be getting the reward
and one interesting trick that they they
did was value conditioning so basically
since we don't have that many
submissions to these competitive
programming problems
it's it's a little bit bad to Simply
discard all of the wrong Solutions which
we have a lot more wrong Solutions than
correct Solutions
um so we want to train on them somehow
but we don't want true
make the model generate wrong Solutions
right so but but there are still some
interesting statistics to be learned
there so
to train on those solutions they
basically
designed their training set so that the
code starts with a comment that says
whether it's correct or incorrect
right so I can make training examples
where the correct Solutions start with
that's the correct solution and the
incorrect one say this is an incorrect
solution and then at test time of course
when generating a program that I want to
be corrective start with a comment this
is a correct solution but that lets the
model and somehow in some way benefit
from from seeing correct Solutions as
well
and the thing that they really pushed in
this paper was simply right so
in in the Codex paper we're talking of
up to 100 samples per problem which is
already a lot
like it's something that's just using
the Codex API you will have a lot of
trouble doing in Alpha code they
massively paralyzed this into 100
000 samples per problem
and
as we're talking
in if you are to participate in a
programming competition and they
actually did run Alpha code on on a real
one
you
can't afford at all just submit 100 000
attempts of solving a problem so in some
way you have to narrow that down to a
very small sets right and in this case
they set the limit of making up to 10
submissions which is kind of the range
of what a human participant would would
do
um
so how do we do that well the first
obvious step is filtering so each of
these problems comes with
some examples of inputs and outputs so I
can immediately discard all the programs
that don't satisfy even those example
inputs that's
already removed like 90 of these 100K
samples so
um then we still have
a quite significant number of programs
that work at least on the basic tests so
what do we do
so what they did was they trained a
separate model that generates inputs for
a program
and
for these generated inputs we don't
really know the
what's the expected output right unless
we are really good at interpreting the
problem statement but even without
knowing what's the expected output I can
use those generated inputs to basically
group The the programs that I have by
Behavior right so so if I generate a
string and I run all the programs on
that input string some of them produce
this result and some of that produce
that result
then I I'm I can't infer that maybe
these programs are semantically the same
right so if I if I had true submissions
to make maybe I would do one of each
instead of true in the same cluster so
this was basically what they did they
generated a lot of inputs clustered the
programs based on their behavior on
those inputs and then picked one
submission from each of the largest
clusters
all right
permissions to like augment training
like how does that help the market
the model better yeah so the question is
how did
how do the wrong Solutions help the
model in any way
um so they didn't really do an ablation
of not training the model on the
incorrect solutions to to measure the
benefit of that specifically but the
intuition is that
even the incorrect Solutions have some
uh interest information for you to learn
from right so you might learn that they
are incorrect for example you might
learn learn bug patterns so you might
learn that if somewhere in the codes
I
forget to close the parenthesis for
example this is probably incorrect
um and since in this case we don't
really have that much training data
any way that you can get to use the
training data that you have probably
helped that makes sense
uh yeah but that's a good question like
it's not it's not exactly clear what the
model
learns from the wrong solution
for your submissions before the time is
up was this the best use of that
information by not looking at that at
all since you submit though 10 you get
the extra students look trying to
incorporate
the feedback you get from The Grater
yeah so in the combinations that they
tried was just basically called forces
you only get like a binary response did
it was it accepted or not
um
yes it's a harsher
than ioi for example
um yeah so the result
uh in offline experiments of basically
solving these problems from a benchmark
that they they collected
was basically that if your sample more
you solve more problems
um so they get this log linear scaling
with how many programs they sample at
all of the the models case that they
tried it's which essentially means that
if you sample 10 times more problems uh
more programs your self rate increases
in this lender rate of six percent
approximately
uh and also with compute so with
how many TPU days they took to train the
model it has
also roughly log Learners KO
um and also TPU seconds span sampling
for each Pro
and
so that was in a like an offline
evaluation written a set of problems
that they they collected but they also
tried this model live on competitions on
this website called code forces and
their model did get non-trivial
performance in a bunch of uh contests so
they they actually ran this in past
context did they run it live
but
they tried to simulate as much as
possible the the setting where you would
be in the competition
and yeah in some of the contests they
would place in the top 30 top 50 percent
or like a medium uh coder in uh and
division two which is important to know
this so so as as they described in the
paper this is like approximately
a few months straight year of training
programming which is
not
to say that they're like wearing these
competitions anytime soon but it's at
the same time not trivia
um
and the main
uh
the main component of getting the
performance that they did was sampling
sampling more programs right so these
they did all this engineering to make
sure that they could sample
100K programs uh
per problem
and
they had
like an accumulation of techniques like
uh the mlm3 trainer on the encoder
um like trying with random assembling
with a random problem tags and the gold
fine tune and all that and none of them
would have helped if at test time they
were just doing a thousand samples so
the effects of all of basically all of
those techniques only showed up when
they scaled it up
200k to a million samples
so
on one hand this shows the potential of
like very simple set of techniques that
you've seen in this class of just
sampling things from Transformers
but taken at this extreme scale
but
of course this also shows a limit right
so
at this rate of having to take 10x more
samples you got six percent more problem
solved this won't get to division one
and anytime soon so we have to do
something different if that's the goal
um
and one kind of problem that
seems to be inherent to these models
if all you're doing is just like
sampling complete programs is this
challenge that humans don't really have
with compositionality
um so this is back to result that was
presented in in the Codex paper
um and if you ask a person that knows
basic Python programming how to solve
problemax and they say it's trivial like
reverse a string for example
and if you separately ask them how do
you compute the length of a string and
they also think that's trivial
if if you give them the problem can you
reverse the string and then take the
length they'll say okay of course like
that's a very simple composition of two
things that are true
um but that does not seem to be the case
with this code language models so the
the Codex author is
did the experiment where they
manufactured tasks by basically chaining
these very simple tasks
and the result was that as the number of
these components grow the probability
that the samples from the model solves
the the composite problem Decay is kind
of explanation
even if the model knows how to do each
of the components individually
so this is
something
which is a challenge to these models and
not to people yet
um
yeah so just some quick takeaways
uh
it seems like Transformers just trained
that scale on code have non-trivial
performance in this task
and these results
maybe for people that
You Know download copilot and just test
it and it sort of works don't seem that
surprising
but for the Perkins synthesis field that
had been for decades working on these
very specific very constrained
domain-specific languages
these results were just unimaginable a
few years ago
and it seems like sampling and testing
and filtering can get quite far
but it also gets expensive quite fast
right so the alpha code for example
just training and evaluating their
largest model
used the equivalent energy of
like 16 American households a year for
example like we can't also have everyone
using these models at this scale all the
time
um
and
the other caveat here of course is that
this setting where you get the extremely
well specified problem
uh which has tests and you can run the
program and determine exactly when it
passes all the tests is very different
from Real World programming right when
where most of the time is spent
uh understanding what's the problem
deciding what to do revising the tests a
lot of time spent editing code and so on
so there's a lot of progress being made
but this of course
still has a lot to do yes
one one question is is it similar to a
question as earlier if we can do error
analysis is it possible because one
thing when we're doing this type of code
generation is if we just assume it to be
right it's a lot harder for us to debug
our code because we didn't provide it
ourselves are there any kind of
like ideas of like things people are
considering in the field for how to go
about like debugging code that was
written by an AI other like AI debuggers
as well yeah
um so the question was about uh
debugging I think they're
true things so one of them is yeah I had
a lot more things that I didn't get true
but one of them was this
um
this notion of automation bias which
people have which is
we have a general tendency to believe
things that are automated and this is
quite a problem for example there was
this study run here at Stanford even
where
it seemed like codex introduces security
bugs at a non-trivial rate for example
and
it's
yeah it's still hard to use these models
without understanding what they're doing
and
the problem of kind of doing this
process more interactively of like
writing the program and then
look at what it does and
then maybe revising the code
is still much harder than just trying to
write the program from scratch exactly
because
well one of the reasons is certain that
we don't have that much data on that
process happening with people right we
we see GitHub which is kind of the
the published version of the code but
all the processes you get from like an
empty file to that
still not recorded
but yeah that's a very active area of
research as well like uh
mothers to revise and edit and debug
yes so our real time
550 oh okay so we do have time to talk
about something okay awesome
um
yes uh
so I'll try to
cover a little bit so
one
a fun thing connecting to to what we
talked about uh back is that codex can
do some simple pragmatic reasoning
so for example if I if I give you these
inputs uh list 132 returns one two three
you'd probably say sorting right it
sorts the list
but what about one two three returns one
two three
probably just identity but it could also
be sorting right it's consistent with
sorting as well
but you would reason that if I wanted to
specify the Sorting function I would
probably give a different input and if I
give these inputs to codecs it does
predict that the first one is sorting
but the second one is identity
just an interesting thing to come out of
just regular language modeling training
um there are also experiments with using
these models in a dialogue style which
is a little bit more about
like the question asked so if I can
actually try to function and then
a model comes up with some
implementation but maybe it has an error
right they can
sometimes describe the change like oh
but can you do it in starting reverse or
only return the top four results and can
often revise what it did
which is quite interesting
um
yes so last
topic here is using programs not as the
output that you have that you want from
the model directly but rather as a
representation for for other things so
one
uh General thing about humans is that
we're our efficacy in a lot of tasks
depends on using external tools right so
if I ask you to multiply these two
numbers one two three four five six
um you can do it but you probably won't
just do it in your head right you use a
calculator or if I ask you what time is
it well you don't keep track of time
that precisely right so you use a clock
or what are the five largest airports in
the world you do some Google search you
figure it out but if you want just
take it out of your head
and when we are training language model
to just give us answers condition on the
question or maybe
on on some context
we're basically asking its truth
come up with the answer all by itself
and
a lot of these problems
aren't reasonably solved in that manner
the problem with just telling what time
is it for example is one that you
fundamentally can't get out of a model
that was trained and Frozen and it has
to produce an output now
and for example
you know
those this language models that came out
last year called Minerva which was
trained on mathematical problems
and and solutions
and it a lot of times got the strategy
right in solving these problems but
still makes a lot of
arithmetic errors so it says okay the
solution would be this number plus this
number equals something wrong for
example
um so
that seems it seems limiting that we're
asking the model to do all these things
by itself
so this open AI paper
from 2021 had this very simple idea of
solving math word problems
uh using language models but providing
them with a calculator
and the way to let the model use a
calculator is basically to assign
a
special input token a special token in
the input such that when the model
generates that token your decoder
instead of keeping conditioning on on
the model's probabilities
will then deterministically do something
with input like call a calculator and
paste the output in in the model's
output sequence right
so they generated this training set
kind of semi-automatically where
solutions for mathwork problems would
have these annotations in angle brackets
and by seeing those annotations at
in the training set and for training you
don't really need to do anything special
at test time you can give the model a
calculator by basically watching until
the moment where adult puts an equal
sign and then once it does instead of
generating from the model you can take
the numbers that come before the call
calculator and then just paste the the
exact output after right
and
this as you can imagine gives a quite
significant boost in solving these
problems because you kind of isolate one
kind of of air like the model what make
arithmetic areas anymore
um
this same idea but taken a little bit
for their
was used to self-worth problems but
instead of the model outputting the
solution in natural language it kind of
interspersed natural language with
python code and the final answer was not
given by the model but by running the
python code that is provided so here's
an example you can look at it in more
detail later
and this also gives a big benefit over
just having the model
try to figure out what's the answer in
its own
um
and more generally there was this paper
that came up on archive
called two former where they basically
extended this idea a little bit farther
um
with a self-supervised approach of let's
say you come up with a list of tools and
you want
to kind of teach them all how to use
those tools
um and in this case they they tried
quite a few
um
two so one of them was a calculator
another was a machine translation system
so when the model output in its
when decoding from the one that was like
empty and a string you go and call
another newer Network which is a
translation and do the translation that
pastes that back
um another one was doing search on
Wikipedia so for example and or or
calling a question answering system
and
with
the right set of techniques to teach the
model how to Output these sequences you
can get a very interesting behavior of
the model kind of deciding on the Fly
which which tool to use
and
yeah so so this is basically the program
here is not
the final result that you want but it's
really just a way for to represent this
usage of external tools
um
yes
um so we talked a little bit about this
before so I guess one natural question
for people graduating Computer Sciences
will I have a job after I graduate or
will codex replace me
and as it turns out
in software engineering a lot of time is
not spent writing code in the real world
right so there's there's one study but
there are a lot more that that show that
uh when you track developers time they
spent a lot of time just reading code
um a lot of time outside of the IDE this
is just ID time right navigating and
five percent is actually added in code
and even editing code a lot of time is
not write a new code but rather like
fixing bugs and
and maintain it
so there's quite a lot of time that's
not spent writing code for people that
are paid to write code
and
yeah and like there's this whole process
of deciding what tribute which is
usually more important than just writing
just muting the thing right in
this is
yeah this still
quite far from from what codex can do
and
yeah there's this notion we talked a
little bit about that debugging is very
interactive we run go back revise and
this is this process is mostly lost by
just sampling more from the model and
trying again basically from scratch
and there's active research even here at
Stanford done using model is also true
to fix bugs automatically read the red
a program has some syntax error how to
go back and maybe change but still very
different from the more open-ended kind
of debugging that people can do
um
yeah of course even all the code on
GitHub is still not all the code that
you can imagine right like there are new
libraries all the time there's internal
libraries for companies that will just
not be on GitHub at any point so there
are challenges in teaching models to use
those as well
um and as we mentioned even if models
can generate code they still fail a lot
of code understanding challenges like
just executing code for example like
asking what this code outputs
um and even fine-tuning doesn't seem
true to solve that problem
and yeah and the other thing is that
public code also has a lot of bugs as
you can imagine and they're being fixed
all the time so training on called
will also mean that sometimes they
generate buggy code and
so you still have to understand what the
model outputs
and their security uh
books that can be introduced by language
models as well
and yes so
just to conclude a little bit past time
a lot of these capabilities were
completely out of reach even a few years
ago this is a really exciting time to be
watching this happen
um and I think there's there's a
fascinating intersection here between
natural language which is extremely
ambiguous and flexible and contextual
and we do it so easily and programming
languages are there these extremely
rigid languages you forget a parenthesis
and compiler has no idea what they're
trying to do anymore
um and we can bridge between these two
words very easily written Now language
models are also starting to
um and besides models that write
programs programs are also just a
general interesting representation for
reasoning for you can represent
mathematics legal contracts this notion
of
calling and combining different tools
um yeah so all of these are very active
topics of research
so
hope you guys enjoy
yes